recently but she's still been taking
money from my card
and that's the only reason we've had any
contact because every week she takes
five or six hundred dollars from my
check and I just don't see how that's
right and she's a
she goes and does dope with my money
like I feel
now I've made over thirty forty thousand
dollars this year and I'm completely
broke because she spends it all on drugs
and
there's clothes in the house that is
mine if so can you tell me what happened
when you came over here this morning I
asked for my clothes and she said I
needed to leave
I've been I've just gotten here I
haven't done anything wrong that window
has been broke
can I just leave if she's not gonna give
me my stuff I really haven't uh I mean
I'm just trying to figure out what's
going on because you know
beating on somebody's door this early
morning
I mean all right
she said to not ring the doorbell for
the top of it I just knocked on the door
a couple times I haven't done anything
that they're saying I mean they've
already made false charges against me
before y'all were talking through the
door at each other
but I mean if if she wants me to leave
I'll leave I didn't know
all right man
can I just go just stand by with me so
he can talk to her what's your name
Andrew Andrew
I just want to be done with her have you
all been cheating on me she's been doing
drugs I've never done any drugs in my
life have y'all had police involved
before in y'all's business yeah and
that's why I'm trying to get my money
back because we're not supposed to have
contact but she's taken 500 each check
why aren't y'all supposed to have
contact Andrew because is there like a
court order
I guess so I don't know I went to court
a while back but did you get arrested
I've been arrested before the last time
I got arrested because they falsified
whatever I mean her mom
dude I don't know what the issue is here
I don't know why I'm so unliked this
girl got hit by a car and I'm taking
care of her right I don't know what the
problem let's get in the shade
but I just like to I mean I work hard
where do you work at William Sonoma
William Sonoma okay I just want to know
why it's okay for her to steal 600 a
week from me and I can't do anything
about it it's not okay so
we're here now
I mentioned that and what'd they say
I mean well it's they pushed it back
till another day so how is she how does
she have access to your money
well a long story is short
when we were together
my phone broke long story short I mean
she's manipulated me into all of it
where she could have all my money
basically do whatever she wants to me
kick me out whenever she wants you know
basically just do whatever and it's okay
because I'm a man there's nothing I can
do about it like other than just let her
do it and or leave but how does she I'm
asking well sure sure I didn't have a
phone because my phone broke so we this
is the dumbest mistake I've ever we
linked our our cards together so her she
can send herself money
from my card this I mean the first
person to touch my money is her and it's
usually five or six hundred dollars
where do you work so how do you get paid
through your job uh well I just recently
um switched it to a paper check so she
couldn't do that and
okay so so you kind of took care of that
problem yeah but I mean it's still three
four thousand dollars set up you know
you got to go to court for something
like that if she's not willing to give
you the money back you've got to take
her to court a civil court
um because y'all live together so it's a
civil issue
we don't live together y'all did though
okay so I'm trying to figure out because
I've told her like hey don't take any of
my money I'm staying at my grandma's and
then all of a sudden